do you remember ray epps he's one of the
stranger figures from the january 6th
saga
he was the guy who was caught on camera
not only participating in but actually
leading the riot into the
capital
we need to go into the capital
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's pretty weird behavior
a lot of people thought it was weird at
the time you can actually hear them in
the first part of that clip they're
chanting fed fed fed
he's saying go and storm the capital and
they're saying no don't storm the
capital this guy's a fed don't listen to
him things then got even weirder because
after the riot as federal agents began
locking up midwestern dads and trump
supporting grandmas for getting a little
too rowdy in the capital rotunda
the guy caught on tape inciting the riot
was never arrested
well now things have gotten even weirder
because the new york times has just
published a glowing puff piece on him
the article is by adam goldman who is a
major propagandist for the fbi led
russia hoax now he writes quote ray epps
has suffered enormously in the past 10
months as right-wing media figures and
republican politicians have baselessly
described him as a covert government
agent who helped to instigate the attack
on the capitol last year
he goes on
during the event he was videotaped by a
right-wing provocateur encouraging
people to go inside the capital on
january 6th in what he described even at
the time as a form of peaceful protest
but what
are they they're defending
according to the new york times
every single person who was anywhere
near the capitol on january 6 is an
insurrectionist and a terrorist that
almost overthrew our sacred democracy
except for the guy who incited
the people to go in there he's
apparently a great guy for some reason
and we should all stop calling him a fed
that's what the new york times wants me
to believe
i don't know if rey epps is a fed or not
but i do know that a new york times puff
piece is not helping his case i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from nick pogbara
who says michael you missed a delicious
opportunity while talking about skinny
people believing they are fat by not
calling them trans fat you are right
i realized this after the moment had
passed
trans fat was the obvious pun i should
have gone for it i
accept the criticism and i will do
better next time uh speaking of doing
better in the future you know sometimes
when i have invested in crypto and i
haven't done it in the smartest way you
want to do it smart you got to check out
alto ira right now go to altoira dot com
michael when you do anything in life
there's one way to do it and then maybe
there is a smarter way to do it so you
might already be investing in crypto
but did you know that you can trade
bitcoin ethereum and over 80 other
cryptocurrencies in a tax advantaged ira
alto crypto ira in particular is a great
way to start investing and trading in
crypto with a tax advantaged retirement
account no commissions no paperwork auto
makes investing in crypto incredibly
easy you create an account in just a few
minutes you invest with as little as ten
dollars
no set up charges you just create your
account transfer the funds start
investing through alto's integration
with coinbase you get secure trading 24
7 150 plus available coins on their
interface including bitcoin ethereum and
cardano there's lots of ways to fund
your account you can make a cash
contribution transfer cash from an
existing ira or roll over an old 401 k
open an alto crypto ira account with as
little as 10 bucks go to auto ira.com
michael a-l-t-o-i-r-a dot com slash
michael start investing in
cryptocurrency today alto ira.com slash
michael
the propaganda is going into overdrive
this puff piece on ray epps is
particularly ridiculous from the new
york times it's particularly shameless
that they tell us all for a year and a
half now that anyone who even thought
about going to washington dc at all on
january 6th is a horrible terrorist who
should be sent to gitmo except for the
dude who told everyone to go into the
capital he's a poor put upon man he's a
victim please stop calling him a fed but
it's it's not just on trump it's not
just on january 6 it's not even just
against the republicans you're seeing
this propaganda throughout our political
process especially
when it comes
to covid so
dr fauci he's making the rounds again
what did i tell you
you know i hate to say i told you so i
told you when dr fauci went into hiding
coincidentally right around the time
that my documentary fauci unmasked came
out coincidentally right around the time
that the michael knowles public health
protection pledge was going around
members of congress and the
congressional candidates around the
country all of a sudden dr fauci
disappears from public view i said don't
you think that he's gone forever he is
going to come back they are going to
bring back kovid before the midterm
elections and what do you know
here comes dr fauci
admitting that maybe the vaccines
haven't been totally super duper
effective so far and that's why we've
got another round of covid
there's no doubt that the vaccines
themselves particularly
vaccine plus a booster at the
appropriate time when you become
eligible for a booster
for more than one booster if you're over
50 years old you get eligibility for two
boosters one of the things that's clear
from the data
that even though vaccines because of the
high degree of transmissibility of this
virus
don't protect overly well as it were
against infection
they protect quite well
against severe disease leading to
hospitalization
and death and i believe that's the
reason
neil why at my age
being vaccinated and boosted even though
it didn't protect me against infection
i feel confident that it made a major
role
in protecting me from progressing to
severe disease
and that's very likely
why i had a relatively mild course
the vaccines don't work which is why you
need to get more vaccines to protect
yourself against the virus that the
vaccines don't protect you against
overly well
you follow that my head is spinning i
love that
listen here the vaccines
do not protect against infection overly
well you could drop the overly well they
don't protect against infection
they it does it
fauci got coveted maxine waters got
covered twice in two months
the
director secretary of hhs got coveted
twice in 26 days i believe it was xavier
becerra
a number of other very prominent people
who are vast and boosted
not only are they infected but they get
infected multiple times in a very short
period of time and so now the
propagandists have to move the goal
posts faculty says listen look
the vaccines don't protect overly well
against infection but promise i promise
you right now trust me everybody they
protect really well against it being
worse it's that phrase that everyone has
to recite when they get coveted even
though they're vaxed and boosted
they say well yes while i contracted
covet i'm so grateful that i'm vast and
boosted because i know based on nothing
that had i not been vaccine boosted it
would have been so much worse and the
the way that they get away with this is
they pretend that they didn't originally
tell you that the vaccines were going to
stop you from catching covid they are
memory holding all of those clips i
tried to dig them back up because i
remembered that they talked about that
and i pulled up all my old links that i
had for it the links are dead they have
been burying this thing on the internet
accounts that posted this on social
media they've killed the accounts i had
to go back to an old episode of my show
to find the clips that had previously
been on the internet that had been
scrubbed from the internet in which
fauci and walensky and biden and all of
the rest of them promised you that if
you got the covet vaccine you would not
be infected with the virus
you're okay you're not gonna you're not
gonna get covet if you have these
vaccinations these vaccines are highly
highly effective vaccinated people do
not carry the virus don't get sick
they're really really good against
variants everyone who takes the vaccine
is not just protecting themselves but
reducing their transmission
to other people and allowing society to
get back to normal get your first shot
and when you're due for your second get
your second shot a key goal is to stop
the transmission to get the immunity
levels up so that you get almost no
almost no
uh infection going on whatsoever when
people are vaccinated they can feel safe
that they are not going to get infected
when people are vaccinated they can feel
safe that they are not going to get
infected what are you talking about we
never told you that the vaccines would
protect against infection
no no there and
liberals
gotta love them
they will tell you with a straight face
the vaccines were never supposed to
protect you against infection no no
oceania was always at war with east asia
they were never supposed to protect you
against infection or transmission the
purpose of the vaccines was always
to mitigate the risk of hospitalization
or death
what about those clips of wallonski and
biden and fauci all telling you that the
point of the vaccines was to stop you
from infection and that it they would
stop you from being infected with the
virus well those clips are gone other
than on this show i
i challenge you to find those clips
anywhere else on the internet i don't
think you will they're probably gonna
scrub this episode because of that
and so this is how the propaganda works
they just rewrite history they memory
whole all the old stuff the vaccines
were never supposed to stop you from
infection the vaccines were never
supposed to stop transmission rayapps is
definitely not a fed move along move
along nothing to see here
and so now that they've accomplished
that part now they're moving on to part
two which is covid's coming back and you
all need to mask up again
good news is that we have the capability
and the tools to address it and we just
need to utilize those tools for example
getting vaccinated if you're not
primarily vaccinated if you're due for a
booster use a booster and when you're in
an area where you have a high dynamic of
infection
and we're not talking about mandating
anything but we're saying recommending
people
when they are in indoor congregate
settings
to wear a mask those are simple doable
things that can help prevent us from
having even more of a problem than we're
having right now
he's not talking about mandate eating
anything yet he'll be talking about
mandating things in about three weeks
and then he'll tell you no i never said
we're not going to mandate anything and
then it's going to go on and on like a
frog and water they're just turning it
up
starting with oh actually the covet
variants are back
oh actually you're going to want to get
your extra booster oh maybe you're going
to want to put that mask on again oh
maybe you're going to want to stand six
feet apart oh maybe you're going to want
to mail in your vote
not show up because
because you know some people told you so
and some people put their nostradamus
hats on and because covet is the only
issue
on which this administration is even
slightly above water and it's the issue
that makes it easiest to cheat in the
election by being able to extend
election day and encourage widespread
mail-in ballots all of which make the
election system much more vulnerable to
fraud that's the words of barack obama
that's not even my point entirely
though i agree with obama on that and
maybe on only that point so they're
going to bring it back we are in
mid-july folks the election is not until
november expect a lot more covid
this obviously makes people very tense
you're probably going to want to relax
when you want to relax i recommend an
all-form sofa right now go to
allform.com i have invited you into my
bedroom you know that i've told you all
about my beautiful helix mattress well
now helix has left the bedroom they've
started making sofas they just launched
a new company called all form they are
already making the best sofas we have
ever seen on this show it is a fabulous
sofa for a lot of reasons one you get to
customize a sofa using premium materials
you do it at a fraction of the cost of
traditional stores you pick the fabric
the color the color of the legs the size
this shape to make sure it's a perfect
fit for your home they've got arm chairs
and love seats all the way up to an
eight-seat sectional and what i really
love let's say you're in a studio
apartment right now someday you're gonna
live in a mansion you can add more seats
as your home grows really really high
quality stuff they have a forever
warranty that is literally
forever to find your perfect sofa check
out allform.com knowles that's all form
dot com slash knowles they're offering
20 off all orders for our listeners
allform.com
knowles
as joe biden flounders expect more covid
if joe biden were doing really really
well in his administration you would not
have the push to bring back covid but
because joe biden is doing extremely
poorly you are going to see more of a
push to bring back kovid because if you
bring back kovid that's the best chance
that the democrats have of not
experiencing a complete political
bloodbath in november and make no
mistake
joe biden is floundering he just landed
in israel he gets out of the airplane
he's still there right on the tarmac he
gives a little speech about how
important it is to keep alive the honor
of the holocaust
i will once more return to the hollow
ground of shepherd vashem
to honor 6 million
jewish lives were stolen in the genocide
and continue which we must do every
every day continue to bear witness
to keep alive the truth and honor of the
holocaust horror of the holocaust
honor those we lost
the truth and honor of the holocaust
cool it with the anti-semitism buddy
a typical biden gaffe we've had a lot of
these biden gaffes recently biden always
puts his foot in his mouth but because
now he is senile he's doing it pretty
much every time he speaks he is reading
things on the teleprompter he's not
supposed to read
he reads lines like repeat the line he
doesn't actually repeat the line he just
reads that line from the teleprompter
he stumbles around parties and no one
wants to talk to him and it's caught on
camera and it's very embarrassing he
doesn't seem to remember where he is
he constantly says very foolish things
but that's not the worst of it if that
were all that were going on
they would lock joe biden in a closet
just like they did during the campaign
and he would be fine and the technocrats
and the apparatchiks would run the
government and things would be
hunky-dory and the democrats would not
be completely destroyed in november the
problem is that everything in the
country right now is falling to pot most
notably
inflation
inflation just keeps going up the
inflation number for june so it's june
2021 to june
2022
9.1
the stuff that you buy
is 9.1 more expensive this year
than it was
last year
this is really bad
people expected inflation to be bad
and then you hit record inflation and
then the next month you hit record
inflation then the next month you hit
record inflation and then you're looking
at june and the analysts at dow jones
predict an 8.8
inflation rate
and it even blows past those horrible
estimates
to 9.1 percent
on the consumer price index
this is
devastating news for the democrats and
for the american people i mean you know
this you go to the grocery store you
order clothing
online for your family you try to fill
the gas tank it's so
much more expensive and inflation hits
people at the lower end of the income
spectrum
much much harder
so it's particularly painful
for working-class americans ordinary
americans really really
bad stuff the only hope they have
i think democrats thought that the
overruling of roe v wade was going to
give them a big excitement boost in
november really fire them up to go to
the polls very few people vote on
abortion and it's split between pro-life
and pro-abortion
that's not going to do it and especially
when you're looking at record high
inflation people can are struggling to
feed their families
and there is there is no social issue
that the democrats are going to be able
to gin up to get over that you want to
talk about democrat financial
mismanagement you're seeing this in
another goodie that they're trying to
give out student loans
a lot of the democrats the really
prominent democrats who are pushing for
student loan forgiveness
have a little bit of an ulterior motive
here they've got a little bit of a
conflict of interest because they
themselves are carrying a bunch of
student debt aoc who is one of the
people leading the charge for student
loan forgiveness
she has between seventeen thousand and
fifty thousand dollars worth of student
loan debt according to financial
disclosures and aoc is complaining about
this and she says it's so terrible that
i have all this student loan debt i took
out all this debt to go to a college
where i didn't really learn very much to
get a degree that wasn't worth very much
and then i just went back and was a
bartender afterward then she became a
member of congress so now she might be
able to pay off that debt she was
complaining she said
i couldn't even go to grad school
because i knew it would require me to
take out so much more debt
as if aoc should be going to graduate
school
as if aoc should have gone to college as
if aoc
whatever education aoc got
it today with educational standards so
far below what they once were it's
probably the equivalent of an eighth
grade education 50 or 60 years ago
just much much more expensive and
professor aoc dr aoc was not able to go
to college rashida talib who again i
don't want to be rude or mean
not the brightest bulb in the pack
not the sharpest tool in the shed if a
strong wind blew through her left ear it
would whistle out her right ear rashida
talib has between seventy thousand and
one hundred thousand dollars of student
loan
debt
forty four members of congress that's
eight percent of the house and senate
combined it's actually probably
significantly higher in the house i
would imagine student loan debt is more
concentrated in the house of
representatives they are carrying
student loan debt so the move to forgive
student loans
is self-serving
and it's particularly self-serving
because people who have college degrees
and advanced degrees are more likely to
make more money and so you're you're
asking the american people as a whole
to pay for the poor financial decisions
of people who are statistically more
likely to make more money than the
average american that that seems really
wrong a tax on the poor to pay for the
rich that that seems pretty wrong to me
doesn't it so it's self-serving it's
wrong it was a poor financial decision
for aoc and rashida talib but i don't i
don't want to just
say
it's all the fault of the individual
don't take out this debt
it is their fault you you should make
sure when you go into debt that you are
going to get a good return on that
investment and i don't just mean
majoring in some
engineering degree or
studying a trade or something a college
education liberal education is a
wonderful thing
if it's not training you for a job the
purpose of a liberal education is just
to train you to make sense of your own
freedom and to read lots of old dusty
books that are not directly applicable
to any job and i think that is worth
something absolutely so you can quantify
a return on investment in a lot of
different ways but right now aoc rashida
talib they're not getting any of that
they're not being trained for a job
they're not receiving a classical
education they probably can't spell very
well i mean they're not getting a high
caliber education they're taking out
tens if not hundreds of thousands of
dollars in student debt to do it the
debt problem is a big issue because debt
is slavery
it is debt is not just an individual
problem it is a social problem when we
have a society where people are mired in
debt that compromises people's freedom
because when you are in debt you have
got to service that debt and you've got
to that will dictate the kinds of
decisions you can make and so i think
this is a political problem i do think i
agree at least in part in principle with
the people are saying we need to do
something about student debt we need to
do something about the cost of college
but i i don't think the answer to that
is just forgive everybody's student loan
debt that's insane all you're going to
do then is incentivize these
horrible leftist colleges to keep hiking
the price of tuition because they know
the taxpayers are going to foot the bill
you're encouraging more people who have
absolutely no business in a college
classroom like aoc and rashida to lead
to go and get these useless degrees in
gender studies or whatever sociology or
something and learn nothing but leftist
indoctrination for four years and then
go out and become more likely to to be
democrats and vote for the democrat
party that's not a good system
at all
we need to figure out a way i'm not
proposing a whole system maybe we'll
maybe do a show in the future on how to
deal with the debt problem but we have
to address the problem in such a way
that it does not incentivize more of
what got us into this place in the first
place we need if we solve the debt
problem we need to do it in such a way
that brings the colleges into line that
does not just
create a factory for democrats and does
not
stick the whole bill on the taxpayers
got to figure out a way i mean if you if
you think about the way
that we in the west considered debt
until the modern era until the 16th or
17th century
there was a prohibition on usury there
was a prohibition on
charging interest on loans that were not
productive
so you could you can charge interest on
loans if the the loan is going to be
invested in some project that is going
to return a big profit the people who
invest in that project have
a right to to receive some share of the
profits there but on an unproductive
loan if you charge interest that is
usury and the loans that we are seeing
for college these days are in many cases
not productive you do not get a return
on that investment so i think
we need to go a little bit deeper than
just
well you took out the debt that's your
problem go get a job kid we've got to go
a little bit deeper than that and
realize this is a social problem that's
going to affect
everybody and we're creating a system
where we're churning out more and more
aocs and that's a very very bad thing
now if you have a country just full of
aocs that is essentially the death of
your thriving country
and speaking of death
you will die someday that's why you got
to check out epic will right now go to
epicwhill.com use code knowles for all
of you adventurous spirits out there
i've got an interesting little tidbit
for you did you know that 100 of people
who skydive will die
did you know that did you know that 100
of people who breathe
will die
it is going to happen baby no one here
gets out alive whether you die jumping
out of an airplane or whether you die
quietly in your sleep a hundred years
from now either way
you need to have a will in place and you
need to do it now is a will is the
easiest thing to put off forever until
it's too late but a will is not just
about you it's about your loved ones
it's about the decisions that they will
face if something happens to you it's
about what's going to happen to your
stuff it's about what's going to happen
to your kids it's about what's going to
happen at your funeral you you just need
to get this stuff taken care of be a
responsible adult do the right thing by
your family go to epicwhell.com use
promo code knowles canada l-e-s to save
ten percent on epic will's complete will
package epic will can set you up with a
will in as little as five minutes super
easy well worth 119 bucks to secure your
family's future without a will you may
as well wrap up all that money and
assets and hand it over to the state
because that is what will happen when
you die no matter where you are in life
you need a will go to epicwill.com use
code knowles today
everybody knows if you want to make
something more valuable all you got to
do is raise the price of it just slap on
a higher price tag and voila you get
luxury bread
designer gasoline
exclusive squares of toilet paper does
that sound familiar the other way to
create value is to offer people
something that they really want and then
charge them a fair price for it so if
you still have not heard dr jordan
peterson has joined us over at daily
wire plus right now just eight dollars a
month gives you access to the full sum
of jordan peterson's intellect his great
new show dragons monsters and men
a four-part mini-series on man
masculinity and the pursuit of greatness
not to mention everything else that we
are doing with daily wire plus
to unwoke the country through fearless
documentaries gripping movies and coming
soon kids content take advantage of our
eight dollar a month special membership
offer go to dailywireplus.com today use
code plus that's
dailywireplus.com right now do not
forget to send in voicemail bags and
written mail bags for the show tomorrow
the mailbag of course is sponsored by
pure talk it is my favorite time of the
week keep those voicemails under one
minute so that i can actually play them
on the show look forward to hearing from
you we will be right back with a lot
more
joe biden is spending our money very
stupidly the democrats in congress want
to spend our money very stupidly for
giving all of their student loans
there are people in this country who are
still using money well
truly one of the best examples of this i
could cite it's a texas
company
that is paying employees
not to have abortions
so you've heard all these stories ever
since the overruling of roe v wade of
woke companies and even not quote
companies even tesla's doing this lots
and lots of companies are offering to
pay for the travel expenses of employees
who want to go out and have abortions in
other states
and it's so self-serving one it keeps
these companies in the good graces of
the woke mob but two it's self-serving
because it's a lot cheaper for these
companies to encourage their their
employees to kill their children than to
have to pay them for maternity leave
than to risk the employees not being
quite so focused on their jobs because
they're thinking about their kids and
maybe they got to leave early one day to
go pick johnny up from school because he
got sick and that's that's just a big
headache for companies they want to keep
you barren sterile they want your kids
dead and they want you sitting in front
of a desk doing spreadsheets not being
spending any time with your family
spending all of your time working for
some other guy so that you can get a
paycheck so that you if you do have kids
can pay some other woman to raise your
kids that's what they want okay
and so they've got all of these
financial incentives to
to encourage you to kill your kids
this great
texas company
is uh paying employees 7 500 bucks
to choose adoption it says these
businesses are ignoring the possibility
that many employees may simply need a
little more help to carry their baby to
term instead of blindly paying people to
end an unborn child's life
companies should consider paying them to
welcome that life into the world uh this
is according to the ceo of this company
i forget his first name but his last
name is rex says that's why my business
has decided to give up 7 500 bucks for
employees who want to have their baby
and give it up for adoption for me the
motivation is equal parts personal and
professional on the former front i'm
passionately pro-life uh yet there's
also a strong corporate case to be made
against abortion and so i really like
this argument that he's making he's
saying
obviously i'm very pro-life but there's
a
business decision here too and he points
out
women who have abortions
often open themselves up to all sorts of
mental health problems
now is this really the motivation for
this policy not really the motivation
for the policy is to save babies because
it's the right thing to do but he's
pointing out there there is a corporate
cost here too because when women kill
their children
they it that gives them a trauma it's
very hard for them they've got to
process that if especially if they don't
realize what they're doing at the time
or if they haven't fully appreciated
what they're doing at the time later on
they realize oh my gosh i killed my
child
of course that's going to give women all
sorts of problems i'm speaking
anecdotally here but the plural of
anecdote is data
i know women i've got women in my family
and friends who have had abortions i
suspect all of us do
and
the women who have had abortions
especially the ones who have had
multiple abortions
they have problems they've got
a lot of problems
dealing with that grief some of them
have become pro-life and they realize
how terrible it is what they did some of
them still support abortion and they
haven't quite admitted that to
themselves and they still have lots of
problems and so
this guy says for business reasons
for ethical reasons
i'm going to
support adoption really really wonderful
stuff i hope a lot more companies do
that as well meanwhile the dems are
doubling down on abortion on demand
without
apology uh the house has been
holding these hearings on abortion the
house democrats called an abortion
witness sarah lopez who said abortion is
not just a necessary evil abortion is
the best decision i ever made
what these restrictions are intended to
do is try and make people try and stop
people from having abortions but
abortion is healthcare
my abortion was the best decision i ever
made it was an act of self-love and i'm
here today to make sure that everybody
who currently needs an abortion who has
had an abortion or will need an abortion
is not alone no matter what the state
tries to force upon us
it's the best decision
that i ever made
she said
i honor my abortion she's if you if you
look this woman up
she has her testimony of how much she
loves abortion
she says i honor my abortion by no
longer giving an [ __ ] about what people
will think if they know i've had an
abortion that goes for friends and
family i've spent way too much of my
life trying to please people i love my
abortion and i will remain unapologetic
because it's the best decision i've ever
made the best decision
i wish i would have known that the shame
that i felt after my abortion was due to
harmful restrictions in texas that are
put in place to stigmatize abortion
not because i did anything wrong from
the moment i found out i was pregnant i
knew i didn't want to have a child and
almost five years later i've never
regretted my abortion all capital
letters she writes but it took me a long
time to reclaim my sense of self because
the patriarchal society tells us our
bodies are not ours so there you go now
you realize when when you hear this
woman speak
at in the testimony you think
it the
best decision you ever made i could
understand maybe you say it was a good
decision i don't regret this but it's
the best decision the lady doth protest
too much me thinks and then here she
admits yeah i felt a lot of shame after
my abortion
but i that's only because
of the patriarchy and the society
and the unfair stigma no darling it's
your conscience is what it is it's
because of the moral reality that even
you with your conscience that has maybe
been dulled and deadened by leftist
ideology is still able to perceive and
you know it's awful and you know you
murdered your child
and what did it give you
what did you get what was the reward for
murdering your child
now you get to be a shill for the
liberal establishment that seeks to
convince lots of other women to kill
their babies so that they can be more
productive in the neoliberal marketplace
and you get to prattle on for an
afternoon in front of a bunch of
degenerate members of congress and then
you'll your 15 minutes will be up and
you'll go back to obscurity and that's
what you get was that worth it was that
really worth it you don't regret it at
all you sure are talking about this for
a lot for someone who doesn't regret
this decision oh this was no big deal
not
doesn't bother me in the least well then
how come you keep talking about how
little it bothers you who are you trying
to convince
who are you trying to convince
you're not convincing me you're not
convincing i think most people in the
audience
something tells me you're not convincing
yourself
either and not convincing the american
people you know this
the momentum is clearly on the side of
pro-life here
you see it legally you see it
politically you see it from the elected
representatives you see it happening in
the states and the libs are very upset
because they're losing their their tight
grip
over this abortion regime so the doj
what's the doj trying to do right now
they're launching a task force to
protect women's reproductive rights this
just came out
story
story from reuters
and they're saying okay the u.s
department of justice
unveils a new task force that aims to
protect women's reproductive
rights the task force will be chaired by
the associate attorney general vanita
gupta
to monitor and evaluate state laws that
will threaten to infringe on federal
legal protections related to
reproductive health care by which they
mean abortion
but there is no
constitutional right to an abortion
that's what the supreme court has
declared those federal legal protections
for abortion are pretty flimsy the
states are going to are going to protect
life and there's relatively very little
that the federal government can do about
that
there is one interesting aspect to this
though and you see it in the reuters
article they say
although abortion is the focus of many
state laws reproductive health care
advocates have warned that some of these
bills could have far wider reaching
implications for women's health beyond
the procedure itself beyond abortion
some of the state bills for instance
recognize personhood from the moment of
fertilization a definition that could
hamper in vitro fertilization treatments
in which doctors collect and fertilize a
woman's eggs in hopes of finding a
viable embryo for transfer into her
uterus this is a great point
and if the democrats were smart if the
pro-abortion people were smart this is
the area that they would really focus on
if they're attacking the pro-life
movement
if they're attacking conservatives and
if they're attacking
the person heard laws that that defend
life from the very beginning because
and i'm i alluded to this a few days ago
on the show but it's going to become a
more important issue as this debate
moves past should we overrule roe v wade
it moves into the next phase of the
pro-life bioethical discussion
if our argument is
that a person is a person from the very
moment of conception
then it is very difficult for
conservatives to defend in vitro
fertilization
because in vitro fertilization
creates
lots of moments of conception
and it does so not in the conjugal act
not in in the old-fashioned way which is
a lot of fun but in a test tube and then
in practice i'm not saying this is
always what has to happen necessarily
but in practice this is virtually always
what happens
in in vitro fertilization
a lot of embryos are created and they're
put in a freezer and they're locked away
and then some are implanted and
sometimes even if
too many
embryos attach and
grow within the womb sometimes abortions
will take place sometimes abortion will
be recommended
because they'll say well you know you've
got now quadruplets and you can't carry
that that's not safe and so it involves
that but even if abortion doesn't take
place
do we really think that it is acceptable
to lock up a bunch of human beings in a
freezer indefinitely
no and one way that some people have
tried to make sense of this or tried to
rectify this obvious evil is through
something called embryo adoption
which has bioethical concerns in and of
itself where people will adopt embryos
that are right now frozen in freezers
and implant them in their own wombs you
don't really know who the parents are
you grow the baby and then raise the
baby as your own
that's one way to get around it but
you're still stuck with the
intrinsic evil of creating a whole lot
of human beings basically just to be put
in a freezer forever
and i know that a lot of conservatives
like in vitro fertilization a lot of
conservatives have personally benefited
from in vitro fertilization because they
were having fertility problems and maybe
they couldn't conceive naturally and so
this was an option for them to get the
baby that they so desperately wanted
but it's an option that has a whole lot
of bioethical problems with it
and i think when we examine the issue
really closely and the libs are already
starting to do this and they're starting
to point to this moral incoherence that
the conservatives have right now
i think when you look at the issue
closely you have to see that a situation
in which if we truly believe human
beings or human beings from the very
beginning
it is
extremely evil to create lots and lots
of human beings
to lock up in a refrigerator
for the foreseeable future
we can't tolerate that
this even if conservatives don't want to
have this conversation it will be had
you're seeing you're seeing the liberals
already begin to poke at this you're
seeing the federal government already
begin to poke at this you're seeing the
media finally beginning to poke at this
conservatives need to have a good answer
here and i'm not sure that the right has
fully thought through ivf or at least
large portions of their life i'm not
sure that they've fully thought through
this
speaking of the welfare of children a
major development in the
alleged case of a of a rape of a child
in ohio this was a story we talked about
it on the show a few days ago and most
conservatives myself included did not
believe the story when it first came out
we just said it the story didn't quite
add up
and the story was that there was a
ten-year-old girl in ohio who was raped
and then she was not able to get an
abortion and joe biden said that her
life might have been at risk and she
couldn't get an abortion in ohio and
therefore she had to go to indiana to
get an abortion because she really
really wanted to get an abortion and the
story just didn't really add up the
media were reporting on it in really
weird ways there were basically no
sources here
the ohio attorney general looked into
this and there weren't reports of this
crime that wasn't really coming up the
pro-abortion activist who first planted
the story
wasn't answering a lot of questions
about it it
actually in ohio if the girl were at
risk if her life were at risk she could
have had an abortion in ohio so it
wouldn't have made sense that she had to
go to indiana if that were the case
so it didn't really add up but a suspect
has been arrested
in a rape that doesn't entirely fit the
the narrative we were told but
but broadly speaking does check the
boxes and does seem to fit this story
so then the question was well i guess
the conservatives just got it wrong but
but hold on why was the story being
reported in such a strange way in the
first place you didn't get the location
you didn't get any corroboration you
didn't get any reports of the crime
itself what was going on here
now we have one possible answer as to
why the story was being reported in such
a weird way again there's still a lot of
questions with this story but we have
one possible answer which is
the suspect who was arrested
in connection with the rape
is an illegal alien
illegal alien gurshan fuentes 27 years
old of columbus ohio was arrested
tuesday and charged with first degree
rape of raping
actually
almost certainly a nine-year-old girl
who then now is 10 years old but she had
just turned 10 years old when the story
really came to light so it might have
been even a 27 year old illegal alien
raping a nine-year-old girl and then it
starts to make sense if the story and
again the details keep keep changing
here but if the story broadly is true
why would the media report on it in such
a strange way oh because they were
covering up for an illegal alien and
this is something this is something you
got to remember it actually ties right
in with
the the new york times story about rey
epps at the beginning
it's not it's not even about israel's
effect or israel's not a fed it in this
case of this horrible rape in ohio it's
not even about
what exactly happened where exactly did
it happen the first question you've got
to ask and when this is a lesson for
conservatives too we have to remember
this the first question you've always
got to ask when you see these stories is
what is the angle of the media
why are the media reporting on this
story in this way you've got to answer
that question first before you can make
sense of what the story actually is
speaking of helping women speaking of
women's issues
elizabeth warren lyowatha
pocahontas
herself senator high cheekbones
is introducing legislation
to
not to help women
not to give women a choice
not to support all that choice and
women's lib that she always prattles on
about she's introducing legislation
to shut down
crisis pregnancy centers
in massachusetts right now
those
crisis pregnancy centers
that are there
to fool people who are looking for
pregnancy termination help
outnumber
true abortion clinics by three to one
we need to shut them down here in
massachusetts and we need to shut them
down all around the country you should
not be able
to torture a pregnant person like that
you're torturing a pregnant person she
says formerly known as a woman you're a
mother or you're torturing a mother she
says if you offer her free or extremely
low cost resources to take care of her
child
crisis pregnancy centers are wonderful
they are actual pregnancy centers to
help actual pregnant women
without killing their children the one
thing you can't get at a crisis
pregnancy center is
uh
killing your children
just like how at planned parenthood
planned parenthood pretends to be a big
pregnancy center that serves all women
and all sorts of women's health care but
you can't get all sorts of women's
health care at planned parenthood their
chief product is abortion so if you want
to kill your kid you go to planned
parenthood if you want help with your
pregnancy if you're if you're a
struggling mother and you you want help
during the pregnancy itself or with
birth or just afterward for young
mothers you go to a crisis pregnancy
center
i have had the privilege of speaking
with all sorts of crisis pregnancy
centers they do
truly they do god's work on earth liz
warren wants to shut them down why
because she doesn't want a choice at the
very least we've got to get rid of this
pro-choice moniker
they do not want a choice they want you
to kill your kid
they do not want you to just make an
informed decision they don't want you to
make an informed decision they want to
shut down
the centers that will take care of you
if you want to keep your child and they
want to federally fund the centers that
will help you kill your child
that's it it reminds me of this
conversation
between betty friedam the american
feminist and samonda bovoir who was the
strumpet of jean-paul sartre and she was
a french feminist and they had a debate
over whether or not
women should have the choice to stay at
home and betty friedan said yeah if a
woman wants to go work she can if she
wants to stay at home she can and that's
great she can have the choice and simone
divorce said no she can't have the
choice to stay home
if women have the choice to stay home
they'll take that choice nine times out
of ten and that's not conducive to
liberation we have to force them to go
to the workplace liz warren is saying we
have to force them to kill their kids
basically if a woman is poor if she's in
trouble if she's worried if she's
anxious it's an unexpected pregnancy we
need to force her to kill the baby
we can't give her the choice because
it's all about power
and more broadly it's about serving a
broader system it's not about a woman's
individual choice
all about power we need to reintroduce
logic and reason to the discussion
the left broadly
has been trying to take logic and reason
out of our politics that's why they're
taking away the meaning of all the words
if words don't have meaning anymore or
if the meanings of words change every
single day then we can't communicate we
can't have a civil dialogue we can't
have reason debate politics ceases to be
this reasoned uh process of figuring out
how best we can live the good life and
how we can have a flourishing country
and it becomes a bare-knuckle brawl for
raw interest and will
i want it and i want it now and that's
why i'm gonna get it that's that's not a
good way to do politics we need to
reintroduce logic especially to this
discussion around abortion
do you know where we're hearing this
from not just from the conservatives in
america not just from the right-wingers
we're even hearing this from
the holy father from the pope who is not
the most conservative guy in the world
some people think he's very very far to
the left and he has
said and done things that would justify
that belief even the pope
was just asked about joe biden's stance
on abortion how joe biden supports
abortion
and here is what
pope francis said about this he said
let biden talk to his pastor about that
incoherence
he called
and frankly i sort of wish that pope
francis were even
tougher here and were even more clear
but this phrase is pretty clear he's
saying that joe biden's defense of
abortion is incoherence and it is
incoherence
to defend abortion is incoherent to for
someone who enjoys the right to life
to advocate denying the right to life is
intrinsically incoherent
you might say it's satanic there's a
video going around i have to get to this
video i meant to get to it yesterday
of of a young woman
giggling over abortion
this woman she's got all sorts of face
tattoos she's got us a satanic symbol on
her chest
and she's watching a video of a kind of
satanic demonic looking figure killing
and torturing a baby and she's laughing
and she's giggling and she's getting a
really big kick out of it and she says
it's my favorite tick tock i've seen
this week
there are all sorts of
secular explanations for this the libs
and some of the conservatives even will
say oh this is really this is about
leftism this is about progressivism this
is about marxism this is about
this is a metaphor they're trying to
metaphorize everything you know satan's
really just a metaphor for a man's
natural capacity for evil
sometimes guys
it's just the devil
and actually it's kind of like that iq
bell curve mean at the bottom end of the
iq curve they say
everything is about
the goodness of god and there's the evil
of the devil and we gotta we gotta
pursue god
right and then the people in the middle
the midwits they say well actually you
know it's a metaphor and it's a metaphor
for this aspect of the internal turmoil
and chaos of man's soul and then you get
up to the really smart guys at the top
and they say no it's really it's just
about good versus evil it's just about
god
and the temptations of the devil and
you've got to pursue god and that's what
this is about
people have been
worshiping the devil
for a lot longer than there has been
leftism or marxism
they all kind of play into the same
thing but every culture everywhere
around the world has had some conception
of god in some conception of the devil
reminds me of that line from antonin
scalia where he was being mocked by a
new york magazine reporter
and the reporter said wait you believe
in heaven and hell he goes uh-huh i do
he says you know i even believe in the
devil
and she he said you're looking at me
like i'm weird do you realize that most
people throughout history have believed
in in the devil that the devil exists
do you
do you realize that many more
intelligent people that you and me have
believed that the devil exists
it's a very important line it's a very
important thing to remember when we're
when we're trying to make sense of these
political problems
sometimes listen to the the dumb guy at
the end of the iq bell curve meme
sometimes all the time actually it
really does come down to good versus
evil those things that we try to write
away as abstractions and metaphors and
just mere images those have reality and
we need to deal with that because we are
imperiling our country and ourselves if
we ignore it i'm michael nolis the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022. on
the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show